good morning
yeah prime minister fearle dear
colleagues
on
the 1st of july we welcomed
the czech republic at the helm of the
council of the european union and today
it is a pleasure to have with us prime
minister fyala to present
the programme of activities of the czech
presidency prime minister dear peter
welcome
uh to the european parliament
prime minister you along with the prime
ministers of poland and slovenia were
the first european leaders to visit kiev
when it was besieged in a message of
solidarity we know
that european unity with
ukraine and its people will be central
to the czech presidency's
agenda and this is why with an illegal
war on our continent your presidency
comes at a turning point
in history so our next steps will be
decisive for our
common future this is not time
to backtrack on our ambitions we need to
address
the economic and social consequences of
the pandemic this is why we must
accelerate our
digital and green transitions and here
the czech presidency can count on the
commitment of this house to make
progress on the fit 455 package as well
as the european trips act and the
artificial intelligence act
dear prime minister diaper just a few
weeks ago you welcomed us together with
all the presidents of the leaders of the
parliamentary groups in prague
and it is in this
constructive spirit that the european
parliament will continue to work
with your presidency on the many
important initiatives on the table on
behalf of this house i therefore wish
you every success
in the coming months so dear prime
minister i will now give you the floor
madam president dear roberta
dear members of the european parliament
madam president of the commission dear
ursula
ladies and gentlemen it's a great
pleasure to be here today to present the
czech republic's plans for our
presidency of the council of the eu this
is the second presidency for my country
but the first under the lisbon treaty we
are building on the excellent french
presidency
it has managed to complete a number of
proposals successfully
it was not easy to find a compromise in
such a difficult
debate like the 50
for a fit 455 package
in the area of climate
or
on new rules for the digital economy
but the most important thing that was
achieved during the french presidency
was a united action to response in
response to russia's aggression against
ukraine
our response was quick
it was tough and
most importantly it was united
six packages of sanctions were not
approved easily a number of member
states had to give up their positions
some of their economic interests and
some of their comfort
but because we were convinced that it
was right to stand up to russia and to
help our friend and ally
i'm in ukraine we did it
together we also granted candidate
status to ukraine and moldova it gave
them hope
and faith in the future
and in joining free democratic europe
our presidency wants to build on this
world
and now
according to the european parliament
tradition
allow me to present the main priorities
of our presidency in my mother language
in czech
damia
ladies and gentlemen
the topics and priorities that we want
to focus on
have been created over
a period of many months but 24th
february 2022 turned most of our plans
upside down literally
our priorities
reflect this new situation
we are in a time
where war is being waged just outside
the eu's borders this is a classic
conventional conflict many of us thought
was a thing of the past in europe
but apart from conventional war
russia is also waging hybrid war
intentionally
sparing a refugee wave
using energy resources as a
weapon and
by target in infrastructure it is
spurring a food crisis
from our point of view it is very good
that our membership in the eu
and in nato protects us from the most
tragic consequences
that that are being faced by the
ukrainian people
when on the 15th of march together with
the polish and slovenian prime ministers
i visited president zielenski in kiev
i saw with my very own eyes the heroism
of ukrainians who were and still are
fighting for their right to exist and
for their right to belong to western
civilized countries
this reminded me that our values were
not a matter of course that they need to
be defended day to day
or not
the values for which ukrainians are
dying these days are values that were
defended by one of the founders of the
modern czech state
the president vaclav havel
it was his inspiring essay from 1996
brought us to the motto of our
presidency
which goes europe as a task
and indeed
europe has many tasks before it
and similarly
the czech presidency of the council has
many tasks before it
the main task for the next months will
be to find a united and strong agreement
on such measures
that will dampen as much as possible the
most negative consequences of the
current crises on our citizens because
inflation unavailability of energy or
the food crisis are
threats that need to be faced and these
threats are best faced together i
believe that both the council and the
european parliament can agree on this
europe as a task
is a commitment for us
it is not a given
it is something that we will need to
work on constantly that we will need to
perfect
also we need to adjust those things that
have not been working as planned
europe needs to lead by example
it needs to reflect its conscience and
it needs to face its challenges
our solutions however need to be
balanced so that
too much focus on one
does not damage or neglect another for
example social peace or our economy
the czech republic will always
very delicately try to reflect all
opinions that will be voiced in our
debates
we have to prevent
a split among us we always have to try
to find the
widest most possible agreement we have
to respect the opinions and position of
others even though we may not agree with
them
havel's words on europe as a task come
of course from another time they come
from another europe than what we have
today but their basic message remains
the same and as strong
our motto is to rethink rebuild and
repower that reflects our challenges and
the problems of the current europe and
our reactions to them
the czech presidency will want to build
a safe and prosperous eu
such an eu that will be true to its
values of freedom and democracy an eu
that will enable all of its citizens to
travel and work freely or become engaged
in the internal market an eu which
understands that we do have an up
responsibility towards the environment
that we need to hand over to the next
generation
um
as as it is and an eu that builds on
what unites us and respects what makes
us diverse that's the eu that we want
and
in terms of this target we formulated
five pillars of the czech presidency
which i would now like to introduce to
you
the first priority
is managing the refugee crisis and a
post-war reconstruction of ukraine
the russian aggression directly or
indirectly is impacting all member
states of the eu the direct consequences
include the most massive refugee wave
since the second world war the czech
republic is one of the countries with
the highest number of ukrainian refugees
per capita
there are more than 3.5 percent refugees
in our population now
we do have our bitter experience with
russian imperialism we know what
aggressive russian policy can do the
czech republic is therefore convinced
that
political and military support of
ukraine from the eu
is in the utmost interest of the entire
eu
with direct impact on the next future of
our continent
[Applause]
the czech presidency will therefore
defend and support the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine
using all tools at our disposal
we will focus on a strong and united
stance against russia
as well as the maximum possible
assistance to member states when
providing military support to ukraine or
when compensating for the consequences
of the migration wave
it is also very important to look in the
future
at the last european council we've
managed to approve the candidate status
for ukraine and moldova i'm very happy
that in this regard we had massive
support from the european parliament as
well i would like to use this
opportunity to thank you for that
but that must not be the end
another very important task of the czech
presidency will be preparing for a
post-war reconstruction of ukraine we
have to focus mainly on
reconstructing their infrastructure
providing basic services
their economic stability and
recovery
that is where the eu must play a
fundamental role after all we discussed
this with madame fonda lyon
and we've demonstrated this on monday at
the conference on the reconstruction of
ukraine in switzerland
the way of ukraine to the eu will still
be long but together we need to strive
that this be a successful way that this
make the eu stronger
the second priority is energy security
the current crisis has fully shown us
how much the future of the eu is
existentially dependent
on others and how important it is to be
independent
especially as far as countries
which are threatening our safety are
concerned i'm talking about russian gas
oil and coal of course the way of the
czech presidency will be
the way of common european projects
which will rid us of our dependence on
russia
the czech presidency will focus
on issues of energy security
to make sure that we can implement
re-power eu as fast as possible and that
includes our energy resource
diversification we are ready to work on
coordinating gas storage facilities
before the winter we support
voluntary common acquisitions
according to the model that we've used
during the covet crisis
while doing all that we have to remember
that we may find ourselves in a
situation where more than ever it will
be necessary to show solidarity between
and among member states
we must not forget
building energy resilience of the eu for
the future through developing our energy
infrastructure
at the same time we need to support all
eu
emission-free energy sources because
these play a very important role when
providing energy security in the eu as
well as in meeting our climate goals
the long-term goal of decarbonizing the
european economy
goes to a great extent hand in hand
with a short-term
goal to de-russify our energy supplies
and that's
that must be our viewpoint
in this regard to become energy
independent on russia we have to use all
options that are allowed by our
geographic situation
given the size of the eu and the number
of member states we may not apply a
one-size-fits-all approach every member
state needs to have the opportunity to
choose such an
energy mix that is the most suitable for
their particular conditions and using
which they will be able to meet both the
climate climate targets as well as the
target of becoming independent on energy
supply from russia
if we indeed want to meet our climate
goals we have to be able to
finance them in the individual countries
i'm mentioning this because today ladies
and gentlemen you will be voting
on the objection against the so-called
taxonomy as introduced by the european
commission i would like to stress
that this is a very fragile proposal it
is a balanced proposal
a proposal that
makes it possible for a number of
countries to meet their commitments
stemming from our climate goals
only
thanks to criteria that were presented
in the proposal therefore i would like
to ask you
to
not reject this very fragile compromise
nuclear energy and gas as a temporary
energy source from safe countries
are the only tool that many countries
have at hand
in order
to
achieve our common climate goals in the
next years
the war in europe has shown how
important it is to boost european
defense capabilities as well as the
safety and security of european
cyberspace that's our third priority
given the current geopolitical situation
it is of key importance that we boost
european safety and security and defense
capabilities nato is in this matter and
natural partner to the eu and the
implementation of the key issues within
the strategic compass is the appropriate
framework we shall work on boosting
european corporation in
boosting
defense capabilities it is of urgent
importance to top up the military
warehouse provisions together with that
member states have provided to the
ukraine we also consider it of great
importance to
develop our defense industry and reduce
our dependence on
not trustworthy countries in the long
term we shall work
on
facilitating joint purchasing of
military material
we are also facing new types of threats
that are being used by our enemies we
shall therefore focus on cyber threats
and
making europe more resilient
vis-a-vis outside threats such as fights
against disinformation the safety of the
cyberspace as well as key eu
infrastructure protection including
institutions
protection and that's what we have to do
together with our partners and allies
our fourth priority is strategic
resilience of european economy
it was the covet pandemic that has
shown some weak points in european
economy one-sided dependency on some
countries europe must
be
indus an industrial and technology
leader
for that it is important to have a
well-functioning
single market without unnecessary
obstacles only that will boost
our european companies
we therefore have to understand the
supply chains better and make them as
short as possible so that the
availability of strategic resources and
spare parts is always a matter of
certainty
what plays a key role here is
boosting free trade with other partners
who share our values the more free trade
agreements of quality we have the more
we can diversify
our contacts and supply chains what i
consider important is also the
digitization and automation in european
industry which also must lead in
innovation and new technologies as well
as strategic resilience of european
economies concerned
food security is of utmost importance
europe has become self-sufficient
in food however the war in the ukraine
also has its implications
on food security and the european union
must respond
we should not forget about the
importance of providing
food in all parts of the world including
the most vulnerable ones not only
because
destabilizing in the food area would
represent
a threat
to europe
ronald reagan said that
freedom is never more than one
generation away from extinction
the same can be said about democracy
that is why
it is so important to have resilient
democratic institutions
and that is our fifth and last priority
long-term prosperity and stability of
europe is based on functional democratic
mechanisms
our society is our
the targets of attacks by those who have
a problem with democracy with human
rights etc and we must defend those
values that is why we shall always
support
and boost
the freedoms fundamental human rights
civil society free media as well as
independent institutions
across europe
ladies and gentlemen there is no doubt
that
we are facing a difficult time not only
due to the russian aggression in the
ukraine we are fighting increasing
inflation ever increasing energy prices
in some countries rising unemployment
in some countries we're facing the drop
in the gdp
we should not
therefore forget about those
citizens who are bearing the brunt of
this socially we must not
forget about those in need i can
reassure you
that
those are issues that
we shall focus on in a systematic way
ladies and gentlemen
the six-month presidency is indeed a
short time
however
i can assure you that the czech
presidency is ready to take its role
actively
we are ready to focus
on an open dialogue to seek compromises
and functional solutions in cooperation
with other eu institutions
i believe that we will be able to
deliver our promises
i hope that with our help ukraine will
soon be on the way to full recovery i
also hope that we will be successful in
the fight against inflation
in ensuring energy security employment
and increasing the competitiveness of
our economies
i trust that we will be even stronger
than we are now ladies and gentlemen i
am convinced that we can count
on
help on the help of the european
parliament which is a pillar of european
democracy
we highly value
democratic divides debates on this floor
and i'm looking for forward for our
debate thank you very much for your
attention
thank you so much
prime minister
for that comprehensive overview and
introduction i give the floor now to the
president of the european commission
also wonderland
thank you
president
mrs matsuola dear roberta
prime minister dear peter
ladies and gentlemen honorable members
we
can all bring to mind the images of
russia's invasion of ukraine when it
started
ukrainian citizens where had no weapons
and they stood tall against the russian
soldiers spoke with the soldiers
shouted at them
flagged quite frankly how absurd the war
was
those images
remind us
of a different invasion
and another example of resistance
against oppression in prague in 68
we saw unforgettable scenes of peaceful
demonstrators taking to the streets
of prague and standing firm against
soviet tanks
and so i cannot imagine
a better country one more suited to
taking over the rotating presidency of
the council in the european union no
better country than the czech republic
the czech people have suffered under
oppression and the people in the czech
republic
know all about resistance the power of
hope
and
the joy that comes with free democracy
now more than ever
we need to strive for freedom
self-determination in the european union
so my dear peter i look forward to the
czech presidency of the european union
over the next six months
are enormous
you better have sum them up with three
words
rethink repower rebuild
and of course the word rebuild calls to
mind first and foremost the
reconstruction of ukraine
i've just returned where i met you also
peter from the lugano reconstruction
conference
and i think we witnessed a very
impressive presentation
of ukraine's reconstruction plan
representatives from more than over 40
countries and organizations agreed on
the lugano principles
ukraine owned
reform focused
transparency
accountability and rule of law
democratic participation
gender equality and
inclusion and sustainability and i think
these are good principles now we have to
fill them with life
and for doing that we need the best and
the brightest on reconstruction
and this is why together with the german
g7 presidency
we will convene such a high level
conference after summer because we all
know never ever before have we mastered
such a colossal reconstruction challenge
so we need all hands on deck
and while we work in these days to help
ukraine win this war
we must also make sure that ukraine wins
the peace that will for sure come
you honorable members
were the first to call for the european
perspective for ukraine
and this led to the historic decision to
grant ukraine candidate status
i think we can all take pride in this
because our union lived up to the moment
we did exactly what vaclav havel
reminded us of
in his speech
which also provides the motto for your
presidency
he has said
it is not
that the united part of europe would
come to harm if it expanded
just the opposite
in the long run
it would come to harm only
if it failed to expand
and i think in these days
that really sounds like a prophecy
now the second task you the czech
presidency identified is repower
the unity and the resolve we show
towards russia will also be key
to re-power europe
and this means primarily
to push forward the very ambitious
agenda of our european green deal
because climate change will not wait
till putin's war is over
and the unprecedented heat wave that
recently struck europe is just the
latest reminder of that
now i'm very glad that both parliament
and council
have taken their positions on fit for 55
so now it's up to the czech presidency
to bring forward the trilogs
and i'm also very grateful for your
commitment dear peter to bring forward
the repower eu package
with repower eu we are mobilizing
substantial substantive new resources
for renewable energy
it is a 300 billion euro plan
to win independence from russian fossil
fuels actually from any fossil fuels
and to do so
we are first and foremost diversifying
our gas supplies away from russia
towards trustworthy reliable suppliers
and our efforts are already making a big
difference i have reported several times
here in the parliament about that so let
me update you about what the latest
efforts are
since march global lng exports
other than russia
to europe have risen by 75 compared to
2021
and lng exports from the united states
to the european union have nearly
tripled
i think even more important is
that at the same time
the average monthly import of russian
pipeline gas to the european union
is now sharply declining by 33
compared to last year
last year june
last this year june minus 33
so we are making progress and that's
exactly what we wanted to have
but we know that all of this will only
work diversifying away from russia and
having energy security of supply if we
speed up the transition to renewable
energies this is the key remedy
now i observe that some say
in the new security environment after
russia's aggression
we have to slow down
the green transition
and this transition would come at the
cost of basic security they say
just the opposite is true
if we do all nothing but compete around
fossil fuels
the limited fossil fuels that are out
there the prices will just go through
the roof and we will fill putin's war
chest and that's exactly what we do not
want to have and therefore the best the
cleanest and safest way
out of the dependency of fossil fuels
are renewables
so
the new security environment
is the best argument to speed up
deployment of renewables
renewals with a homegrown
they give us independent from russian
fossil fuels they are more cost
efficient and they are cleaner than
anything else so let's take the
opportunity and really invest in the
renewable energy
honourable members
but we also need to prepare now
for further disruption of gas supply and
even a complete cut up of of russian gas
supply just to give you
a figure today
12 member states already directly
affected
by partial or total
cutoff of russian gas
so it is obvious
putin continues to use energy as a
weapon
and this is why
the commission is working on a european
emergency plan
we will present this plan and the
necessary instruments by mid july
member states have their national
contingency plans that's good
but i think we need european cooperation
and we need common action as 27.
we need to make sure that in case of
full disruption
the gas flows towards where it's needed
most
we have to provide for european
solidarity
and we need to protect the single market
as well as industry supply chains
and here honorable members
we should never forget the bitter bitter
lesson that we learned at the beginning
of the pandemic you remember it very
well at the beginning we had egoism and
protectionism closed borders
export bans you name it that led only to
disunity and fragmentation
but with european unity and coordination
we then after a while have the key
remedies to overcome this brutal
pandemic
so let's keep these principles in mind
as always let's hope for the best but
prepare for the worst i know this is
hard work ahead of us but like in the
last month
unity will be key to our success
honorable members
you know
as well
as i do that in all member states
there are worrying economic trends the
covert crisis
has
deepened debt levels and just when
economies were starting to rebound
russia began a ferocious attack against
ukraine this accelerated inflation in
all
sectors
the food sector the energy sector and
all in between
at the same time investment is key
to ensure a transition a green
digital resilient transition and that is
why we need to rethink
rethink my dear peter
is part of your motto and it is very
appropriate
we need to rethink the way
we
drive growth
we have a very different political and
economic
context we know the rules of economic
governance
we need rules that recognize our need
for investment and the need for healthy
budgets
the budgetary
viability
and indeed growth go hand in hand
we will present the results of our
assessment of economic governance during
the czech presidency look at the single
market
you talked about this
you talked about our trade relationship
these are two major assets in tackling a
crisis the main drivers of
growth we need to rethink the way we can
strengthen those assets further we need
to look at new
free trade agreements one for example
signed last week with new zealand that
is a good case in point
the new agreement will help to bring
about a 30
increase
in trade between the european union and
new zealand
for the first time
it enshrines unprecedented commitments
on social and climate issues
this shows
that when democracies are strong they
can deliver results in the interests of
their citizens in his arch speech
watson spoke about
europe as a task
the task of europe today he said is to
rediscover its conscience and its
responsibility it's beautiful end of
quote
and this is exactly what we will
continue to do with the support of our
czech friends
dear petter
i've seen it with my own eyes and heard
what you reported to me when i visited
czechia last week and thank you again
for this wonderful reception
the czech people opened their hearts and
their homes to refugees
they do miracles to thousands and
thousands of ukrainian refugees hosted
in the czech republic
and this is
in the harvard sense
europe with a conscience and taking its
responsibility
this is europe at its best long live
europe thank you
thank you very much
dear
commission president uh before we go to
the round of political groups i have one
quick announcement uh in relation to the
decisions
by the import econ committees to enter
into winter institutional negotiations
pursuant to rule
71 paragraph 1 announced at the opening
of the session on monday 4th i have
received no request for a vote in
parliament by members or political
groups reaching at least the medium
threshold the committees may therefore
start the negotiations and now on behalf
of the epp group i invite the group
chairman for the webinar to take this
law
but i'm president of the european
parliament european commission the vice
president
your prime minister dear peter peter
vyala welcome and thank you so much for
the presentation of the ideas of the
czech presidency
and the czech presidency comes at the
right moment
thanks to you europe is first of all
back in the czech government as soon as
you took office you appointed a minister
for european affairs next to you mr back
for the first time after 12 years
there is again a european minister in
the czech government and that's why i'm
convinced that the czech presidency will
be a pro-european one as a good one and
a successful one
and i also want to underline that with
this new presidency this is new
government after the government of
publish i think it's also a symbol of
rule of law and also a symbol of
separation between business interests
and public interests
the czech presidency comes at their
right moment
uh useless on the line reminded us
already on the brock spring i want to
add
the
resistance against the nazi germany
and the peaceful revolution in 1989
the czech republic is the symbol
that brave and determined fighting for
democracy and freedom
will be rewarded at the end the czech
presidency is the best suited to lead
europe when it comes to support ukraine
for its fight for democracy freedom and
justice european democracy and freedom
are breathing jack spirit
the czech presidency comes at the right
moment
when it comes to the future of europe
now we can only survive in confrontation
with putin if europe is the lighthouse
of free democracies in the world that is
why we finally need a convention
to renew the idea of european democracy
we must take the people of europe
seriously when it is about
european decision-making the conference
of the future of europe made it clear we
need to strengthen our democracy and you
spoke about this the czech presidency
wants to do so
we must introduce and live the lead
candidate principle that people have a
say about who is in the future the
commission president we must strengthen
both the european parliament and the
national parliament we need a
re-parliamentarization of the european
union the european parliament should
have full rights on legislative
initiatives and decide on the eu budget
uh
on together with the national
parliaments and that's why the czech
republic can play their key role after
the check of the french presidency
had some leftovers for you to continue
your work and let me be also clear on
this politically union idea
i think it's good that we talk to each
other no doubt about this but for me
it's not yet clear what is the key idea
behind this political union
and i have also to say that this was not
part of the debate here in strasbourg in
the future of europe conference so it's
a new idea i think we should base our
future ideas on the process of listening
to people
and finally the czech presidency
uh comes at the right moment when we
have to focus on the most urgent tasks
and that is about
inflation and especially the energy
security
as a first step i support draghi's
initiative to impose a temporary cap on
price that the european union countries
are willing to pay for russian natural
gas
let us use our european economic power
against putin's blackmail attempts
and when the crisis will probably arrive
in winter when nordstrom 1 will probably
not continue to deliver gas we need a
binding a legally binding mechanism of
solidarity in the european union and i
think it's also needed mr prime minister
to go for an extraordinary
european council for this we need
decisions we have to prepare for the
crisis and not wait for the crisis
ladies and gentlemen the czech
presidency comes at the right moment
you can fully count on your epp group to
deliver europe needs your leadership
europe needs a strong czech presidency
thank you very much mr webber and now i
invite the leader of the s d group
hiracha garcia perez to take the floor
gracias thank you very much
thank you president thank you president
fonder lyon prime minister
we're starting off
another complicated presidency now with
the war in ukraine and its consequences
it seems almost as if covid was
relegated to the past but these are
overlapping crises and we have to delve
deeper
the two years ahead of us in this term
are going to be decisive we know that
instability is going to continue and
that's why it's extremely important to
stay on course when it comes to the big
changes and transitions the green
transition and the digital one and in
order to deal with unexpected turbulence
prime minister fiala we support the
priorities of your program strengthening
freedom security and prosperity for
everyone
we need to manage the refugee crisis
recovery for ukraine after the war
energy security and we need to reign in
inflation but we won't be able to do so
without taking into account the impact
that this will have on people in other
words social policies and that is what
our group is concerned about
yesterday we would have liked more
references in your work program to
social issues
but today i'm very pleased that you have
taken up our plea to have a social
summit in order to make sure that the
social policies that we agreed on in
porto last year are brought up to date
this is excellent news prime minister
because we have to make sure that we
protect ourselves from external threats
but also from internal threats we have
to make sure that we fight against
injustice inequality and poverty because
these will also be threats jeopardizing
the european project that is why we have
to talk about the social impact and
another issue is gender equality because
we have made a lot of progress along
this path but a lot remains to be done
for example in order to make sure that
we have pay equality it would also be a
good gesture if your government ratified
the istanbul convention because it is
the main legal instrument that we have
in order to fight against gender
violence
and of course the rule of law is key and
i very much hope that your presidency
will make a difference prague is at the
geographical heart of europe it is the
symbol of a people's
struggling for democracy and their
rights and i hope that you will be able
to plead along these lines in the
visagrad group you know that values
these values are not negotiable and that
eu cannot
renounce defending the rule of law
now under the
czech presidency the council can finally
organize serious and efficient hearings
on how the rule of law situation has
deteriorated in hungary and poland on
the basis of article 7
and
unanimity is not necessary the only
thing that is needed is political will
authoritarian populism is a threat for
europe and for all its countries
and not all visa governments are the
same we are aware of the fact that
prague now has the opportunity to
be leaders when it comes to this new
push for freedom a new democratic spring
we have to listen to citizens in order
to do this and that is why i'm sorry to
see that your program doesn't refer to
the conference on the future of europe
citizens are expecting much more and we
have to push forward reforms and we can
only do this if we go beyond unanimity
in important areas we have to
tackle the
challenge of migration head-on we cannot
waste any more time the eu has to flesh
out the word solidarity prime minister
you chose a slogan that is spot on for
your presidency europe as a task this
is a quote from bachelor of havel
he said this in his speech when he got
the charlemagne prize and we still
represent a project based on solidarity
a project about the future that we're
all building day by day you can count on
the socialist group in order to work
side by side with you in order to mold
this future this common future based on
peace prosperity freedom over the next
six months thank you whereas i give the
floor on behalf of the renew europe
group to dita charanzova
prime minister
the czech presidency
is starting at an extremely difficult
time continuing war in the ukraine
uncertainty about future development as
well as the deteriorating
economic and social situation in europe
i personally welcome the steps that the
czech republic the czech presidency is
planning vis-a-vis the ukraine
supports to the ukraine is of key
importance for the safety and security
of all europe
however the center point of the whole
presidency must be the citizen
the citizens should not be the last as
mentioned in your speech but rather
first they should come first
hand in hand with ukrainian crisis you
need to acutely deal with providing
sufficient energy for this winter
to the citizens as well as companies how
to unblock ukrainian ports to
prevent further crisis and influx of
refugees how to maintain the
competitiveness of europe in ever
increasing inflation and energy prices
czechia must become a crisis manager
with a crisis
plan for europe
prime minister
when you
ask in brussels about the first czech
presidency dating back to 2009
that i took part in most people will
remember the peculiar czech sense of
humor that you are well familiar with
and the world media however
concluded by saying that we had
excellent officials and diplomats how
but bad politicians
you have an opportunity
to improve the image of the czech
republic and it's an opportunity not to
be missed thank you
mr ransomware next on behalf of the
green group george soleil
thank you madam president
malan commissioned president vice
president via your prime minister
you are taking over the presidency of
the council in challenging times this is
beyond doubt
one of these big challenges is our
dependency on fossil fuels you mentioned
that
environmentally but also geopolitically
we are paying a high price for this
dependency
turning towards a green economy is key
to tackle our climate challenges but
also to get rid of very inconvenient
dependencies as we see these days and
this should be the council's presidency
goal too
we have to be not only ambitious but
also consistent
and this is clearly not the case
with the taxonomy proposal this proposal
doesn't live up to our ambitious
ambitions but
also doesn't live up to the consciously
consistency of our policies
for uh climate neutrality
that's why i hope later today this
parliament will bow down this uh
proposal
prime minister there are reforms like
energy transition that we can undertake
and the current treaties but others
demand treaty changes in that sense i
must say that i regret that the czech
government is one of the signatories
rejecting the possibility to change the
treaties as you know very well this
parliament is indeed pushing for a
convention to amend the treaties and i
hope that the council activates article
48 the sooner the better
our demand is also in line with the
conference on the future of europe
conclusions which amongst amongst other
things asked for putting an end to
national vetoes and i hope you will help
implementing what european citizens
asked us to do and finally i welcome
that the program of your presidency
includes a force towards advancing
negotiations on the path on migration
and asylum it is high time to close this
deal we urgently need a migration and
asylum policy that strikes a fair
balance between our demographic and
economic needs the need for solidarity
between member states and the need to
put fundamental rights at the forefront
i ask you prime minister to work in this
direction thank you very much
thank you very much mr soleil and now i
invite the chair of the id group marco
zandi to take the floor
grazie
thank you very much president
president vandalian
vice president prime minister
i already had an opportunity to speak to
you
a couple of weeks ago
and it was a very useful debate and i'd
like to wish you the very best of luck
for your work
you and your country
are managing the presidency of the
council
at one of the most critical moments that
this continent
has had to face
it's critical from an
external point of view with the war in
ukraine but also at the internal
level you and your colleagues have
listed many of the problems that our
citizens within the european union are
facing
with great deal of difficulty
we share the priorities of your
ambitious program that the
czech presidency has sketched out for
the next six months
but now we need acts
citizens need
facts they need decisions
we have spent much too much time over
the last few months
okay i mean i understand that the
situation was difficult but we have been
trying
too hard to try and take the decisions
whereas we still need answers
on the war as long as we are not able to
put an end to this war
inflation will not
fall
energy prices will not fall and we will
not manage to save the ukrainian people
and nor will we be able to sell save the
peoples of their own countries our own
citizens so that's why we need to act we
need to protect and defend ukraine with
the final objective of having
as early a piece as possible that's what
ukraine citizens
want and that's what europe citizens
want
on the economy
i've said it before and i'll say it
again
the european institutions haven't done
enough now we need strong exceptional
measures because the situation is
dramatic energy bills
have been multiplied five-fold
companies are not managing to uh balance
their
accounts at the end of the month
the economic prospects are
bleaker than they have been for
a long time we need to act
now
president weber you reminded us of the
proposal that the
italian government put on the table at
the last council the longer we wait
before we put a price ceiling on the on
gas supplies
the more money we'll be giving to uh
russia the more
possibility we'll be giving the russians
to hold us in blackmail
uh with
their gas supplies
i think the polish prime minister made a
good proposal
let's also put a
ceiling on the co2 price under the ets
scheme
i don't agree
when
the european institutions say
that the green transition is not having
an impact on energy prices
that the green transition isn't part of
the problem it's not me that's saying
it's the european central bank they
officially confirmed repeatedly over the
last few months that inflationary
pressure
is also being caused by some of the
policies that are being pursued we need
pragmatism we need concrete decisions
because otherwise
we will not be able to speak to our
citizens we will not be able to
understand
uh or allow our citizens to understand
how important it is for us to act
together on behalf of the eci group
veronica verezianova
madam president
of the european parliament madam
president of the european commission
prime minister fiela
allow me to thank you for presenting the
plans of the czech presidency i believe
that these fully correspond to the
problems europe needs to face
it is self-evident that there are two
topics of the utmost importance both are
connected to ukraine first of all a
post-war reconstruction of ukraine
because a functioning and prosperous
country on the eastern borders of the eu
is important not just for ukrainians
themselves but also for us the member
states of the eu
approving
ukrainians candidate status is a good
first step in this regard
now we need to come up with specific
reconstruction plans promises of help
that we're hearing left and right need
to materialize in bank accounts that
will pay for this reconstruction
the current energy crisis is also a
topic that connects back to ukraine
what is happening is the very thing that
we have been warning against how many
times did we talk about the risks of
completing nordstream 2 now we have to
very quickly work on providing enough
energy for our citizens at a reasonable
price we have to stop lying to ourselves
that will be able to pick and choose the
energy resources that we like and that
we regard to be green or less green our
main task is now to mobilize all
resources available at least in the
short as well as in the midterm
we're seeing this happening in germany
already
for example which is increasing the
percentage of energy out of dirty coal
where it has the option to use clean
nuclear energy we need to use
nuclear energy we need to develop new
modular reactor types
today at noon will be voting on the
objection to the taxonomy
in this vote we will see who is really
interested in our citizens that they
represent here we will see who is
interested in how citizens will charge
their electric cars how they will turn
on their lights how they will provide
heating because without nuclear power we
will not prevail thank you
thank you miss brzezinova next on behalf
of the left group katarina konechna
thank you madam president
ladies and gentlemen prime minister
it is a rare occurrence to agree with
something prepared by the czech
right-wing government of petrophila i
may surprise a lot of you but out of the
five
presidency
priorities um i consider four to be
correct the problem however is elsewhere
the reality is often
tougher than
the eloquent worlds of the government it
is
unrelenting only in
seeing that the czech republic is
assisting in the cancellation of the
veto right for member states it forces
czech citizens to purchase energy with a
surprise surcharge even though it's been
produced cheaply the czech wages being
one third of the western ranges often
have to pay higher prices for everything
the czech idea of cyber security is just
switching off the websites that they're
not comfortable with without a court
ruling
and it is on the road to privatizing the
remainders of
government-owned companies and
price increases are more than uh double
than in the rest of the eu and the
program for the uh czech citizens is bad
as well as leaving companies to its own
devices with
banning combustion engines the
corruptions scandals among uh government
officials
is rampant i wish that
we are not treated as the czech citizens
by the czech government what the czech
republic needs and especially during its
presidency
it needs a government where the citizen
comes first
rather than excuses and empty promises
not by words but by deeds shall you know
them
good luck not only to the czech
government but to everybody
thank you mr konechner and now on behalf
of the non-attached members balajit vege
thank you very much
prime minister president
the czech presidency
comes
at a time
[Music]
when we
are facing economic and security
challenges that are unprecedented we
haven't had these kind of challenges for
centuries
for decades rather and we have to stand
united we need common sense
and we need a long-term vision
it's extremely important to focus on the
real problems so we want to ask the
czech presidency to help us in order to
make sure that all members hungary and
poland can tap into
financial resource the financial
resources that have been earmarked for
them
uh these are countries that are dealing
with the lion's share of the refugees in
an unprecedented crisis in europe at the
same time as
we're facing very serious economic and
energy crises
the issue of security of energy supply
isn't ideological but physical do we
have the energy sources or not
we hope that the czech presidency will
be emphasizing the importance of
security of energy supply and our main
task is to help its citizens families
and businesses thank you very very and
now i give the floor back to prime
minister fiala to respond to the first
round
ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much for your
contributions for your questions for
your interest in the czech presidency
and of course
thank you very much for all your words
of support that we've heard here this
morning
when i introduced our presidency's
themes i told you that we
chose several key aspects
our five priorities of course
include a wide range of topics
which in some cases
are already within the long-term agenda
of the eu of course the czech presidency
is further developing these
there is a
document
on the planning of individual policy
sectors
and
please read that document it is
available on our presidency's website
you will see that many of the topics
that you say you didn't hear
in
my presentation you will find in that
document i didn't mention them here for
time's sake so thank you very much for
all that you've said i'll try to respond
to several specific questions that were
voiced here today i believe that from
the speaker's interventions it it is
very clear how every one of us realizes
the major challenges and risks that we
are facing in the eu today
in most of your contributions you've
said that you want clear steps common
steps
courageous steps being taken by the eu
to remember the citizens who are facing
repercussions of the war in ukraine and
all of the rest of the aspects that i've
mentioned in my speech and that
madame fondelion mentioned in her speech
at one point i was slightly worried
that
our unity is such that even the
communists would
say well done to me but i'm reassured
that they didn't in the end um and this
rather showed me that we were heading in
the right direction now
to the specific questions the conference
on the future of the eu this was
mentioned by
mr weber
it was mentioned by several others
the czech republic is of course fully
committed to engage in implementing the
outputs of the conference of the future
of the eu
we do realize that there is an interest
in the european parliament to call a
convention
and to initiate the procedure on
changing the european treaties but i
have to say that this is indeed a
marathon
i would like to correct one thing that
i've heard
mr soleil i believe
we are not in principle against a debate
on changing the treaties but we are
convinced that this will be a long-term
exercise and first of all we need to
have proper debate
so that we be prepared for an in-depth
discussion on changing the treaties as
such it will need time
as our
feasibility study says on the
implementation of the of the outputs of
the conference on the future of the eu
the um
documents of the european commission
clearly say that even within the current
legal framework we can
implement a large number of proposals
from the conference in the future of the
eu we can concentrate on that but
calling a convention and initiating a
treaty change cannot be done hastily
it could
hamper any implementation of anything
else that came out of the conference the
future of the eu so we do not try to
avoid institutional questions we want to
tread
wisely so that we attain those changes
that the eu citizens indeed wish for
several of you
or rather to be very specific it was
madame garcia and several others have
mentioned
how important it was to reflect the
social dimension the social policy of
our presidency
i must say
that
in many
of our priorities there is a social
dimension already there speaking about
available energy
energy at a reasonable price energy
security
all of these have a social dimension
or we can speak about european
economy resilience
about
how we
make sure that we are not as dependent
on resources from
certain producers on certain products
that we then keep further processing in
the eu that also has a social dimension
we're talking about employment and about
all of those other things that touch
day-to-day citizens lives in the eu so
there is a social dimension
in our policy
so we do not perceive this as
a separate area of our presidency it is
fully integrated into our overall agenda
we're also speaking about the need to
rebalance between environmental
measures the social aspect and our
economy that will be the major task of
the next months and here we need to face
our challenges because if we
only focus on one aspect without
rebalancing it with the other aspects
if we give one of them priority
what we can expect is a disruption in
our social peace and that's what nobody
wants
to be very specific because the
questions uh on the social aspects have
been voiced i can tell you that we were
preparing several conferences on this
topic in prague
energy poverty
uh on that there will be a conference on
the 24th of october
integrating handicapped persons persons
with disabilities there will be a
conference on the 20th and the 21st of
september
and
fighting child poverty there will be a
conference on that at the beginning of
july in the next few days so we are even
focusing on these aspects these are
examples of specific actions that the
czech presidency will undertake they are
under preparation and they will deal
with the questions that you've mentioned
i agree
that we need to
[Music]
be strong and specific in energy economy
and many other aspects
and i do not share the skepticism
saying that we are not able to do this
we are not willing to do this so the ets
was mentioned yes and this is a
long-term problem
many countries
are happy with how the ets works many
countries are unhappy and sometimes
we're seeing major problems for example
in the czech republic but lately we've
been able to achieve a certain
compromise in the sense that we will
emit more allowances on the market so
that the price
not increase
so much i believe this is one example of
what we can do if we want to achieve a
reasonable compromise
that everybody can then in the end
support
we have to remember
that for example as far as energy is
concerned and please do remember this
for me
one of the greatest
or how shall i say the best things
in this awful tragedy that the war in
ukraine undoubtedly is and given all the
consequences given all the repercussions
one of one of the best things that could
happen to us in the eu and i'm seeing
this in council meetings
is that we've learned to listen to one
another
we've learned
to
listen
be it from the west being from the south
listening to central and eastern
european countries
which have experience with russian
imperialism and which do recognize the
threat that we're seeing from russia
we in turn have learned to listen to our
southern member states who have their
particular problems with addressing
issues stemming from north africa et
cetera this listening to one another is
extremely important but we have to take
one another seriously as well as far as
energy is concerned there are countries
in them in the eu
that have an energy mix where they are
independent of russia then there are
countries on the other hand which are
extremely dependent on russia for
example in case of the czech republic we
are 97 dependent on russian gas getting
rid of this dependency is our task
number one but it will take several
months or maybe even several years to
achieve this to achieve it we need
solidarity from everybody else there are
countries which can rely on renewable
energy sources they've done a tremendous
amount of work and now today they are
miles ahead of other countries who have
not done their homework maybe we can
even call it their mistake but they
simply do not have natural conditions so
that they may use renewable energy
sources and their energy mix needs need
to be reflected and i repeat this is the
czech republic but several other states
as well if we are unable to finance
nuclear energy as a clean energy source
those countries will not be able to meet
their climate climate goals they will
not be able to get rid of their
dependency on russia let us remember
that our initial conditions our natural
conditions and many other things
make us diverse
and what we have to try to do is when
meeting our common goals we have to be
able to find different paths and respect
the parts that individual countries wish
to take let us all please remember this
i'm sure we all agree on our overall
goals
achieving those goals especially in
exceptional times exceptionally hard
times like these
that
can only be attained if we create a
certain level of freedom for decision
making in individual member states
if we respect the diverse speeds at
which individual countries want to
achieve these goals if we do not
approach this in a diversified way the
results cannot be good
and my last remark
i just have to say this
i'm sorry
someone mentioned that in my speech
citizens came last
i believe it was a czech colleague who
mentioned this that is not true
citizens came first
my entire speech was about eu citizens
in all our priorities we remember the
citizens
if we cannot manage the refugee crisis
if we cannot manage to help ukraine to
stop russian aggression
who will pay the price our citizens
you mentioned
food you
mentioned the food corridors you also
mentioned the word inevitably ukraine
yes it is all very narrowly tied
together
that is how important ukraine that is
how supporting ukraine is important for
us we have to do our utmost that ukraine
win
ukraine
is connected with anything that we may
discuss here today and you mentioned
this miss karan zava yourself
speaking about energy speaking about
energy self-sufficiency speaking about
trying to have energy at a reasonable
price what are we talking about we're
talking about citizens
resilience of european economy also has
a social dimension
reinforcing defense capabilities in
europe that has a social dimension that
is all about our citizens resilience of
democratic institutions of course even
here who else is a democratic
institution than the citizen
so the citizen
and their well-being
are very dear to us across all our
priorities
thank you very much once more for all
your questions i hope i've answered most
of them thank you prime minister
and continue with the
the speeches of the different colleagues
starting with miguel a soy driver for
one minute and a half
thank you madam president
um prime minister
um
i'm frankly very happy that to see that
it is you whom i can welcome
this morning the priority of the czech
presidency reflect reality if we want to
preserve our freedom and our safety we
have no other choice the help to the
ukraine in the fight for freedom and
independence using all means available
including
support to ukrainian refugees we
there are no other priorities than the
uh independence from russian
energy sources and strengthening defense
capabilities we need to support social
cohesion food security and we must
preserve the citizens trust and i'm
happy to see that you're facing these
challenges with courage and i thank you
prime minister that you lead by example
in solidarity with ukraine and i would
like to thank the czech citizens that we
lead by example in helping and
integrating ukrainian refugees europe
has set itself ambitious objectives in
fighting climate change not that we
would be naive thinking that we will
save the world on our own but we want to
lead by example um
to show in others like china brazil and
others that they can join us in the
efforts and here i believe the czech
presidency will play an important role
and i wanted to ask you a question
on this are you ready to finalize
negotiations with on the legislative
package in that matter and do you think
it's realistic to achieve the objectives
for climate neutrality and at the same
time become independent from russian
sources but i believe that question has
become superfluous because you have
spoken clearly on this
let me only emphasize that i want to
wish you
and your presidency
lots of strength
now
europe needs concrete actions uh europe
is our common task thank you now i give
the floor to radka maksova for one
minute
[Music]
thank you very much madam president
prime minister
ladies and gentlemen dear colleagues
there is a great task ahead of us the eu
is facing many challenging the war in
ukraine inflation pandemic
the czech republic has been stressing
cooperation and unity when dealing with
these tasks
we need to be united when solving social
questions protecting the vulnerable
assuring fair opportunities fighting
violence
apart from the crises that you have
mentioned in your speech i would also
like to draw your attention to things
that you have not mentioned in the czech
presidency's priorities
where seeing a mental health crisis
apart from the obvious impact of on
people's lives
we are we're also seeing the price of
more than four percent of our gdp
challenging times require us to take
bold steps in protecting protecting
citizens mental health please make sure
mental health is protected because in
activity can cost us up to 80 000 lives
per annum
lives which we would lose in europe as a
result of mental problems the second
issue i would like to mention is wage
transparency women still earn less than
men in the eu and this will be a lot a
great challenge for the eu presidency to
manage the trilogs for pay transparency
believe me that we as the socialists and
democrats will wish you all the best but
at the same time we will make sure that
you will not overlook our social
problems thank you
veteran for one minute
thank you madam president vice president
prime minister
as you yourself said the french
presidency of the council of the
european union saw historic steps taken
to build a strong europe a europe that
is a climate powerhouse thanks to
positions adopted on the climate package
social and educational powerhouse with
the agreement on a minimum wage in all
member states a strengthened and less
naive trading powerhouse a digital
powerhouse setting global standards
regulating platforms and above all a
geopolitical powerhouse
standing by ukraine and neighboring
democracies as they fight for freedom
against russia
you can build on this excellent record
your presidency comes at a key juncture
what is at stake is a need to hold the
course remain united we don't need
unanimity but we should stand united we
need to complete negotiations on the
climate package
finalize
the agreement on the due diligence and
tools to counter the use of economic
worship parliament is resolute working
to this end we need that same commitment
from you to work in the interests of all
europeans
i wish you the every success during your
presidency
for one minute daniel's right
thank you madam president
dear mr fiala you promised your voters
that you will kick out the corrupt that
you will defend the rule of law
and you won against andre babish
now you're taking over the presidency of
the council and i'm sure you know that
corruption is not only an issue in the
czech republic but in the entire eu
where babish tried to prevent justice
the polish government is trying to take
over the entire justice system and where
babish took millions orban and his
cronies are taking billions not just
millions
autocrats are the biggest threat to the
eu and i'm very thankful that you're
taking the autocrat that is invading our
neighbor ukraine very seriously but i
think you need to take those following
the putin playbook inside the eu
equally seriously
it's up to you to set this on the agenda
and to make sure that the attacks on the
democracy and rule of law by the polish
by the hungarian government play a role
in your presidency and the decision of
freezing funds to hungary will come to
the table of your presidency make sure
that the promise you gave to your voters
doesn't stop at the czech border and
that you're delivering on that promise
also in your presidency thank you very
much thank you very much mr freund next
is dominic tarczynski for one minute
madam president
prime minister
first of all i'd like to thank you prime
minister for
your bravery
i'd like to thank you for your presence
in kiev with mr kaczynski and mr
moravietsky that's very important to
everyone in europe i believe so i'd like
to i'd like to thank you for your
bravery
and
for your presidency i'd like to wish you
our bravery because it's needed
so i hope you will stay strong
because it's up to you up to your
perseverance what is going to happen now
in europe
we do remember 1968
when soviets
invaded your country
and i can assure you now you have our
full support
because we do know how it is to be a
slave
of the soviet union
and russia
so i can assure you poland will never be
a slave
of the soviets poland will never be a
slave of the soviet union and russia and
i do believe that czech republic will
never be a slave and this is my wishes
to you and to your people stay strong
stay firm thank you very much thank you
next is johan radish bog down for one
minute
ladies and gentlemen your excellencies
the czech republic as a member has been
a member of the eu
since may
2007 and since 2007 uh member state of
schengen first law have said that oil
should not be more important that human
members than
human
rights
or rights of nature of nations romania
has been a member of the eu since
january 2007 four years later it had met
all the conditions to join schengen now
it's 2022 but we're still
waiting
for 11 years romanians have been kept at
the door of an exclusivist club the most
um
loyal people in the eu the most euro
optimism has
undergone a lot of suffering
and is now treated with indifference we
are denied the right to full freedom uh
culturally and historically but also
politically are we then why are we um
why do we wonder that there are
political movements that uh
go against the euro system
europe has been shaken by a war in
ukraine should learn that indifference
has its price it allowed the crimea to
be annexed and
and now um this
attack on ukraine romania doesn't is not
in danger thank god but we are because
we are members of eu and nato but
there's another danger that romanians
keep leaving their country because it's
considered a second class country it's
not fair it's not more it's not
democratic when the rules are applied um
with uh with a discretion we're not this
is not a democracy
and my question is when will romania
will
when will remain truly be a priority for
the eu this is unacceptable done next is
helen
thank you very much president
commissioner prime minister
now the three presidencies france czech
republic and
sweden are going to be working
to
for greater equality i'm pleased to hear
that but nevertheless i'm concerned that
equality issues
were not identified as a clear priority
for the czech presidency
threats to equality and women's human
rights are very serious
the pandemic has led to an increase in
violence against women abortion rights
are
in danger in the united states but also
in the eu it has taken
it will take three generations at this
rate before the eu is an equal
union
so prime minister when does the czech
government plan to ratify the istanbul
convention
how can you ensure that the eu as a
whole does the same
and
what will be the major equality
priorities under the coming semester
microphone
wait wait miss beer a microphone okay
okay
prime minister
this could not be more appropriate
the european union and its future is in
good hands with the czech republic
the czech republic is in favor of
enlargement prague can
liaise between east and west and ensure
resilience bolster resilience the
eastern partnership
bears the stamp of the czech republic
dating back to 2009 you opened the door
for dialogue between the eu and armenia
azerbaijan georgia moldova
and ukraine
that courage
and
forsightedness is needed now the
european union needs to redefine itself
look at its common energy policy greater
independence but also internally we need
to get our own house in order ensure
that we can take swifter decisions these
reforms are needed in the european union
urgently the czech republic cannot slam
on the brakes rethink rebuild re-power
that is needed for the european union
itself czech republic needs to drive
that forward be the driving force that
the european union needs thank you is
marcel collier for one and a half
minutes
thank you madam president um
dear commissioner
their prime minister their minister dear
colleagues the chief government
and the czech permanent representation
to the union worked tirelessly to get
ready for the presidency of the council
and i would like to thank for that
it is only natural that the presidency's
priorities react to the russian
aggression in ukraine and its
implications therefore i believe that
the presidency's priorities are well
identified
at the same time other urgent problems
such as the climate emergency did not
magically disappear
they are also reflected in the
presidency's priorities and i'm really
happy that the czech government under
your leadership prime minister supports
fit455 and agrees that only zero
emission cars can be sold on the
european market from 2035.
and here comes my main question prime
minister
what is your measurable goal for fit 455
how many legislative acts do you plan to
finalize in the negotiations by the end
of the presidency
and please let me finish by reiterating
how important the presidency's
program is it is an important signal to
europe that shakia after years at the
periphery is back at the core of the
european project
that czechia is again dedicated to a
strong safe and united europe and last
but not least it is also very important
signal to us in this parliament that
voices of members of the european
parliament from your political group uh
who are as a matter of fact not overly
present in this debate are not the voice
of the czech government thank you and i
wish you and us great success in our
presidency thank you thank you mr kalaya
next is the lord's montserrat for one
minute
thank you very much madam president
we would like to welcome the czech
presidency
we have three main challenges in the eu
unity vis-a-vis putin and supporting
ukraine and preparing ourselves to
rebuild a destroyed country and to and
dependence
energy dependence on
russia and we have to make sure that we
put an end to the destabilization of
european democracies and fight against
disinformation we have to fight against
rampant inflation we have to ask
countries to reduce taxes
so that we don't have uh the country
filling its coffers but while citizens
households and businesses going bankrupt
not having enough money to make ends
meet and we need quick disbursement of
european funds and we have to make sure
that europe leads the world on the
global stage it's about political
relations trade relations in latin
america and africa we have to fight
against china that is stronger and
stronger on these stages we can't just
be play second fiddle
there's populism and communism
in
cuba venezuela and other countries let
us be ambitious and let us rise to the
occasion
for one minute
said
that seeing europe as a task
was absolutely right
the next few months will be a very
difficult task for us to fulfill
we have to ensure that we have unity we
should not only be struggling against
russian aggression but we have to be
rebuilding our economy
strategic autonomy
has to be uh
built up
and we have to
ensure independence from russian energy
that is the task of the czech presidency
also looking at the macro financial
rules we need to have a look at
this carefully and this will be a task
for the czech presidency member states
have to deal with their own problems
first of all
poland and the czech republic
know a famous singer
who talked about with a famous song
about four 000 problems
but in this institution you have friends
we will be supporting you in this task
europe is a task that we have to fulfill
together
yes prime minister you you said here in
your intervention that uh
uh
the reform of the european union and the
change of the treaties is a long-term
exercise
that's true but if it is a long-term
exercise you have to start early
i did
certainly be to be ready for 2024
and
as you know the president of the
parliament has triggered article 48
has sent you a letter
and my request to you and the request of
the whole parliament is that you react
smoothly and swiftly to that request
it's a limited request
to end unanimity and the national vetoes
in the
european council
because the war in ukraine shows very
well that that is the problem in the
european union for the moment
we need three months to have an oil
embargo in european union three months
to decide that because of national
vetoes
we have no agreement now on this minimum
taxation a multilateral agreement
in an international framework because of
the blackmail and the veto of whom of
hungary
and at the same time
we have the whole migration package in
limbo because of what of national vetoes
so the war is showing that the need to
change so my request to you is to
smoothly say yes to the request of the
parliament to have a convention and not
to play games about that minister like
yesterday
preparing a letter
with the other member states
with a silent procedure
in saying yeah but we wait for a more
bold proposal of the parliament or
article 48. so the council is now saying
we cannot say yes thank you do the
limited proposal because they asked for
a board proposal that's playing games
minister say yes to what the president
of the parliament has asked for don't
only use the words of harvel
thank you mr verhofstadt next is
gwendolyn del boscarfield for one minute
prime minister i am now going to do my
very very very traditional and boring
speech
about article 7 procedure which i do
every new council presidency because
this procedure is now in your hands and
we have to rely on you to make things
happen
it was four years ago that this european
parliament launched article 7.1 of the
treaties against the hungarian
government about the situation
of democracy of rights and of freedom in
that member states and since then we
have been working tirelessly with eu
presidencies all eu presidencies to get
the council to move forward
every time you delay the procedures not
only are you giving the hungarian
government more leverage to dismantle
the rule of law in their own country but
you are allowing them to threaten the
whole european project
we count on the czech presidency to be
one of those that show leadership
and are broking
this cycle of inertia and lack of
courage
thank you miss del boscorfi next is
ludek niedermeier for one minute and a
half
your speech marked an excellent
beginning of the czech
presidency i
appreciate your call for unity and
consensus because that's what
we rely on in european union i
appreciate the references made to vaclav
havel
and europe as a task is a well
chosen motto what i consider to be the
tasks of essential importance first
a strong position
against russia's
aggression to the ukrainian and be ready
for the
gas to stop the second priority i
considered to be
finalized the trial oks our companies
are as well as citizens needs to be
clear about our policies and objectives
especially finalizing the key files in
fit455 i hope you succeed in that
and in order to be successful indeed we
need to be able to listen to one another
and to seek appropriate compromise when
needed and that's the way the parliament
works
we should not
to forget however that these compromises
need to be explained to our citizens
explain them why it's good not only for
the czechs but for estonians austrians
and other all the europeans that's the
only way to maintain supports and also
achieving our objectives thank you i
wish you every success hire next is
sophie and debt for one minute
thank you
madam president
mr prime minister three points first of
all on migration the council for years
now aims for a minimal and incomplete
package that is best summarized as
fortress europe whereas the european
union a european parliament wants a
coherent package
that will allow us to actually manage
migration now we have asked the council
to commit
together with the european parliament to
take the entire package
across the finish line before the
european elections but the council is
hesitating will you here commit together
with the european parliament to
finalizing this package before the
election
secondly i agree with kiefer hofsta you
said on treaty change oh we need to go
slowly slowly but the world is changing
at a dizzying speed and europe is
lagging behind intergovernmental europe
is spectacularly
ill-equipped to deal with crises or to
have a coherent vision for the future
this european governance system is
dangerously weak and outdated and the
european council is becoming a threat to
the future of the european union if you
keep blocking reforms you have a
responsibility to the citizens and not
to national governments i expect you to
act in the interest of the future of
europe thank you thank you very much
miss intervelt we have multiple requests
for catch the eye
i will distribute them again across the
political group starting with stelios
imperopolos
cross
thank you very much president
you have very substantial priorities for
your presidency because it's true that
europe has an unprecedented challenge
with the war of aggression in ukraine
and it also comes
close on the heels of an other
unprecedented crisis the covet 19
pandemic so we have to tackle all of
this and i'm very happy to see that your
priorities include
the issue of rare diseases as one of the
pillars and this comes at a time
when during your presidency we will
start negotiations on health related
issues such as the overhaul of the
legislation on orphan drugs
the eu has to be at the heart of
innovation in order to make sure that we
are trailblazers when it comes to
developments and so that we can also
manufacture
here on european soil because this
affects the quality of life of our
citizens thank you
thank you
president
dear roberta my thanks to
the czech prime minister for his
presentation
i would echo
what other meps have said
it is important for parliament that we
see progress on institutional
matters
that perhaps
did not get much of a mention
during the presentation i however have
every faith in the ability of the czech
presidency
to steer debate in the council as
requested by parliament
and triggering article 48
as requested in our resolution last
month so that the council can start to
assess
our proposals
begin discussions take note of our
resolution
let there be no doubt or confusion here
help us
to take forward the important work on
the new european electoral law including
the introduction of a new european
constituency
okay mr kanyas does not seem to i think
there you are
thank you very much president
the czech presidency priorities
include
making process
progress when it comes to the
negotiations
free trade agreements with third
countries including latin america and in
the indo-pacific that's a very good idea
very convenient given that all of this
was paralyzed during the french
presidency but i was very surprised to
see that given that this will play a key
role in the future of europe uh
i'm referring to the trade chapter
because we need more markets and more
suppliers i was very surprised i was
taken aback that you didn't mention this
in your speech
you have completely forgotten about the
trade chapter so i am startled uh i
would like to believe that you're going
to
really push forward the ratification of
these trade agreements and that you will
kick-start what stalled back in 2019
because uh some member states threw a
spanner in the works so i'm very i would
really like
your reassurance that you will breathe
new life into the ratification of all
these outstanding trade agreements with
latin america thank you that you are him
brucing
thank you very much
well europe is a task that's a difficult
task indeed
this debate has showed that to all of us
i would like to thank you very much for
your calm and your voice of reason
you have referred to our experiences the
experiences of central and eastern
europe
including our experiences with russia
now i would like to respond to what geva
hofstadt said he's trying to uh
teach you lessons it seems
well when it comes to knowledge about
the czech republic and poland i don't
think that
anyone beats us
some people say that putin's a democrat
well please wake up
listen to the voices of reason who know
better than you
who know what makes putin tick
president macron and chancellor schultz
were on the phone when you were in the
ukraine
thank you madam president prime minister
i
like to start by saying that i really
appreciate the priorities of the czech
republic and i wish you the best of luck
coming from romania i know your country
very well i was a child when in 1968
your country was invaded by russia and i
was very happy
when my parents were actually grieving
together with the checks
but uh prime minister you talked about
solutions here about talked about
reasonable solutions to solve your
priorities one of them is the internal
market
you mentioned it yourself
it is fragmented prime minister i am
vice president of
the committee uh on private uh on the
internal market and uh i've been
working on this topic uh for 16
presidency presidencies you are the 17th
we cannot have schengen and non-schengen
we cannot have second-class citizens and
pre-please prime minister
do not disappoint me like the french
presidency did
because my country uh meets the
technical requirements since 2011 this
parliament had voted on multiple times
on romania entering the schengen area so
please prime minister uh complete your
priorities uh with the union of the
internal market without having two
internal markets schengen and non-shang
thank you so much
floor on behalf of the commission to
vice president xefcovich
dear president uh the prime minister
honourable
members of the european parliament
allow allow me to address you in my
mother tongue
because checks for slovaks will forever
be brothers
thank you
now
there was a description of our hopes
and what
uh the similarities with the prague
spring
we know that hopes came back years later
with the velvet revolution it brought
back democracy to central europe and it
also brought back central europe into
the heart of europe
there are so many parallels
with what is happening today in ukraine
and that is why we understand ukraine so
well
we really can put ourselves in the shoes
of ukraine and that is why you have
provided such uh strong support
i'm sure you've been able to draw
conclusions from the debate and that is
that your five priorities were good
choices
and that is because you have really
prepared very well in the run-up to your
presidency we're talking about really
hard work which led to tweaking the
priorities because of russian aggression
in ukraine and
the changes on the world stage
we're going to continue working to hand
in glove on many fronts
first of all we'll be working together
when it comes to the conclusions of the
lugano conference and the uh recovery
plan for ukraine
the czech presidency but also the
different member states have a lot of
experience that they've garnered
when it comes to enlargement and we can
share this experience with moldova
ukraine and georgia and the western
balkans security of energy supply is
going to be another important plank
the eu is going to have to focus on this
we know that we need crystal clear rules
that can make sure that there is
solidarity among member states against
this
very difficult backdrop
there is no doubt about the fact that
we'll be
learning our lessons from the first
months of the covert pandemic
on the
20th of july
we'll be working on our specific
proposal and we're going to continue
improving this within the council and
with the presidency and the european
parliament uh to the fit for 55 because
here in indeed the timing is of assets
the urgency is clear just this week we
have seen the terrible melting of
glaciers in marmolata
heat waves and fires in spain i would
say across the europe and if you look at
the calendar 2030 is indeed around the
corner therefore i would like to
reassure you they will have all support
we can provide you with for the trilox
with the european parliament because now
the
uh positions general approaches are
approved what's in europe european
parliament took place so now we have to
work on the compromise to make fit455
uh happen
i also would like uh to
agree with you mr prime minister that
what we need is to strengthen strategic
resilience of the european economy and
to work on technological
and industrial leadership of europe and
part of strong economy is strong
economic governance
and
therefore
our plans is that
already in the second half of this year
we will work uh on
new strong economic governance
framework we will provide the
orientation on possible changes to the
economic governance
of today after uh summer break so it
would be well in time prepared for 2023
and we plan together with the czech
presidency uh to foster consensus uh
where we can find the best possible
solutions how to deal with the debt
sustainability how to make sure that we
will work on sustainable growth through
investments and uh
reforms
upon
premiere
speaking about the conference on future
of europe
i would like to reassure the honorable
members that
the concrete follow-up by the commission
will be presented to you in the first
speech of the president of the european
commission in september in her address
on the the state of the union and
immediately the follow-up would be
worked in the next commission work
program and if it comes
to the convention
once the decision is taken commission uh
will play its role to make europe
stronger and better in the future
pan premiers are motorcycles
now the czech presidency slogan is based
on a quote from havel europe as a task
i firmly believe
that the czech republic is going to
um
manage this very successfully
and we're going to be working
hand-in-hand with the czech presidency
which is well prepared and well
motivated so i wish you the best of
success and we look forward to working
hand in glove with you there's very
broad debate that touched on on many
many subjects the prime minister the
floor is yours
thank you very much madam president
thank you everyone for a very lively
debate for many
questions many remarks i believe that
all of this is pointing at and it is in
indeed a signal for me pointing at that
the priorities of the czech presidency
have been chosen very well you've drawn
my attention to other aspects that i
could not mention in my speech for time
reasons but we will address these as
well
we take them very seriously very quickly
very briefly i will try to reflect some
of the remarks that were made maybe let
me start
in a more general manner speaking about
the conference on the future of the eu
and certain
level of impatience perhaps that we've
heard here
very emotional impatience in mr
hofstadt's speech that we've heard
i want to say that
speed
and emotions
may not at times be the get the best
friends of good results
i am concerned with europe's future i am
concerned with the eu project i've
worked on the eu for 30 years
and i remember certain failures that
we've had remember for example the
european constitution
remember certain reforms that were
ill-prepared or came too fast
leading to problems leading to a
weakening of eu support among citizens
i don't believe that we can attain
better results if we are hasty we have
to carry out a proper debate we have to
listen to one another we must not think
that whoever wants to run faster is the
better european
um prioritizing haste over debate if we
listen to one another if we respect one
another if we remember our common goal
then i believe we can achieve good
results
the czech presidency will not
be an obstacle to anything we will keep
leading the debate but we will be
leading the debates so that it leads to
good results
i would like to react to certain
questions that were voiced as far as
article 7 was concerned the czech
presidency
will take steps
take those steps that a presidency
country should take
as a mediator as a moderator and we will
try to achieve a peaceable result that
is our task that is what a presidency
country should be doing
concerning questions on equality between
men and women and i'm intentionally
mentioning what was mentioned repeatedly
the 18-month council program
and
the priorities of
men and women equality this is one of
our priorities of course we will try to
progress in trialog on
pay transparency
for men and women and we will initiate
the procedure on debating the proposal
on enforcing the role and independence
of bodies that play key roles in this
regard
equal opportunities for young men and
women in the postcovid recovery of our
economy here we will organize in prague
on the 3rd and 4th of october conference
and as far as the very specific question
was concerned on rare diseases
also in prague on the 25th and 26th of
october there will be in prague and
experts conference
trying to achieve an improved access to
medical care for patients suffering from
rare diseases and we will also be
discussing the eu's plan on rare
diseases
the main goal
as far as the free trade agreements were
concerned the main goal of the czech
presidency is to improve the landscape
here and conclude free trade agreements
as you can see from
the statistics europe has been lagging
behind certain third countries and of
course this is something that we want to
change
what will be key in this regard are the
indo-pacific latin america and african
regions where the eu
by
in by being inactive is um
yielding the the areas to our rivals and
we want to address this concerning fit
for 55
as far as this package is concerned
we're preparing for the next stages of
the negotiations we know the position of
both co-legislators the council as well
as the ep and our task will be now to
start the talks one of the priorities as
you know of the czech presidency is
energy security there was also a
question mentioned repeatedly
about the schengen space bulgaria
romania
what i can tell you
is that as far as
croatia bulgaria and romania we are in
contact with their governments and we
intend to enlarge the schengen space
free movement of people is something
that we take very seriously and i hope
we will be able to achieve progress
ladies and gentlemen uh meps
thank you once more for the opportunity
to speak to you this morning to present
the czech presidency priorities thank
you for your contributions thank you for
the debate thank you for your kind words
of support
which i appreciate very much and i am
glad to be able to summarize the
discussion that the european parliament
uh sees things in the exactly in exactly
the same light as us and i see the
cooperation between the parliament and
the council as key to achieve what the
eu citizens expect from us the eu
citizens expect from us to be able to
solve and resolve the
repercussions consequences of the war
increasing prices of energy of food and
of other goods the destroyed
country that is ukraine of course the
cause here is russia with its aggressive
policy even in this area we can play a
major role by continually supporting
ukraine and
putting pressure on russia our task is
to reconcile all of these activities in
one presidency we have things to follow
on from we can follow on from the
success of the french presidency as i
mentioned at the outset and we have
certain challenges and problems that
we're facing that are massive yes but
our task
will be to
address all of these at once to improve
the lives of our citizens to improve the
competitiveness of european economies to
assure
safety and security in the eu and for
the eu thank you once more i look
forward to our cooperation
thank you very very much prime minister
thank you dear colleagues
for this debate we look forward to your
presidency as you've seen from all the
comments by their colleagues uh thank
you and good luck this debate is closed
and it will be followed with european
council and commission statements on the
conclusions of the european council
meeting of the 23rd and 24th of june
you